>> Neil: FIRED UP OVER
CONTINUING LOCKDOWN.
RIGHT NOW, ARIZONA THE LATEST TO
EXPERIENCE PROTESTS.
A LOT CLOSER THAN 6 FEET
TOGETHER.
THE PROTESTERS ARE SAYING,
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
WHAT HABITS AND THESE PROTESTS
IN MICHIGAN AND VIRGINIA AND
NORTH CAROLINA, THAT SOMETIMES,
THEY MISS THEIR OWN MISSION BY
DOING THAT KIND OF THINGS THAT
PREVENT DANGER OR HEALTH HAZARDS
THEMSELVES.
THAT IS CONGREGATING TOO CLOSE
TOGETHER.
TRACE GALLAGHER HAS BEEN
FOLLOWING THIS AND SO MANY OTHER
PROTESTS.
>> THAT’S BEGAN WITH
PENNSYLVANIA.
THE MOST COMPELLING PICTURES.
THIS IS HARRISBURG.
WE WILL SHOW YOU THE CAPITAL
WHERE A FEW THOUSAND RALLIES
SHOWED UP TO DEMAND THAT
GOVERNOR TOM WOLF REOPEN THE
ECONOMY.
VERY LITTLE SOCIAL DISTANCING.
WHILE THE PROTESTERS ARE MAKING
THEIR CASE OUTSIDE, BOTH MEMBERS
CONTROLLED LEGISLATURE ARE
PLANNING TO COME BACK IN SESSION
TWO LIMIT GOVERNOR WOLF’S POWER
TO MAINTAIN THE SHUTDOWN.
AS ALL OF THIS COMES, THE
GOVERNOR IS TARGETING MAY 8TH AS
THE DATE FOR A LIMITED
REOPENING.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THINGS LIKE
CONSTRUCTION, RETAIL SHOPS,
ONLINE CAR SALES.
THAT’S GO TO ARIZONA BECAUSE
THEY WERE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
RALLIES.
A LOT OF PEOPLE STAYED INSIDE
THEIR CARS CALLING FOR THE
GOVERNOR TO REOPEN THE ECONOMY.
THEY WERE PRACTICING A LITTLE
BIT OF SOCIAL DISTANCING.
THE PROTESTS AROUND THE COUNTRY
WERE ORGANIZED IN PHOENIX AND
PENNSYLVANIA ON FACEBOOK LIKE
MUCH OF THE OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
HERE ARE A FEW OPINIONS FROM
PHOENIX.
WATCH.
>> THIS WHOLE THING WAS A
MISTAKE FOR THE BEGINNING TO
SHUT DOWN AMERICA.
WE DIDN’T KNOW IT AT THE TIME.
IT WAS PROBABLY A GOOD DECISION
AT THE TIME, BUT NOW IT’S CLEAR
THAT THERE IS A MISTAKE.
THERE COULD BE A STAGED OPENING.
THE HEALTH AND WELFARE OF
ARIZONA CITIZENS ISN’T
JEOPARDIZED FIRST.
>> WE SHOULD POINT OUT THAT
ARIZONA GOVERNOR HAS TARGETED A
MAY 1ST OPENING, BUT HE HAS
GIVEN VERY FEW DETAILS IN THAT.
IT’S ALSO POINTING OUT ALASKA,
MONTANA, COLORADO PLANNING TO
OPEN THIS WEEK.
KIND OF LIMITED OPENING.
CALIFORNIA HAS NO TARGET.
IT’S GOING TO BE 85 DEGREES HERE
THIS WEEKEND.
WONDERING HOW THE BEACH CLOSERS
ARE GOING TO PLAY ACROSS THE
STATE.
>> Neil: DO A LOT OF YOU FOLKS
FEEL EMBOLDENED BY THE PRESIDENT
AS THAT IS THEIR RIGHT AND
LIBERATE ONE CITY, ONE STATE
AFTER ANOTHER THAT HE IS
ACTUALLY GOT THERE BACK?
>> THEY DO.
YOU TALK TO THESE PEOPLE, AND
THEY BELIEVE THAT THIS IS THEIR
RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO GO OUT AND
SAY ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
A LOT OF THIS REALLY CAME
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE WILLING TO
PLAY ABOUT THE RULES.
YOU TALK TO PROTESTER AFTER
PROTESTER, AND THEY ARE WILLING
TO PLAY BY THE RULES TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT.
WHEN THEY BELIEVE THAT THERE IS
OVERREACH AS IN THE CASE OF
MICHIGAN, WHEN THEY CAN’T BUY
GARDENING TOOLS AND PLANTS AND
SO FORTH, THAT IS WHEN THE
FRUSTRATION LEVEL STARTS TO
BUILD.
THAT’S WHEN YOU SEE THESE KIND
OF PROTESTS BUBBLE UP ON
FACEBOOK.
IF THEY START TO ENGENDER A
GREAT DEAL OF SUPPORT.
SO WE FIND THAT PEOPLE ARE
WILLING TO PLAY ABOUT THE RULES
AND SOCIAL DISTANCE.
THEY KNOW IT IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO.
WHEN THEY BELIEVE THAT OVERREACH
IS HAPPENING AND GOVERNORS ARE
NOT LISTENING TO THEIR DEMANDS
TO REOPEN THE ECONOMY, THAT’S
WHEN YOU HAVE THIS BUBBLE UP
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.